this is jocko podcast number 266
with echo charles and me jocko willing
good evening echo good evening
and joining us again tonight
is dave burke good deal dave burke good
evening dave
good evening so we've knocked out two
chapters
of marine corps doctrinal publication
one tack four
which is called competing and today
we're going to delve
into the third chapter now we have had
expectations in each one of these of
doing more than one chapter
i don't think we're gonna make it
especially because
three has a lot of good stuff in it and
four
is longer so i don't wanna get halfway
through four
anyways so we're gonna delve into
chapter three
and before before we kind of kick that
off
in the last chapter and throughout the
book
thus far the marines have been calling
competition or describing competition
as an enduring conditioning an enduring
condition
it's enduring it's always happening
always
and then when we got done i think it was
with the first
chapter and we did an underground
podcast
and i i talked about that clip from
there will be blood i have a competition
in me
i want no one else to succeed and i i
kind of talked about this fact that i
i related to that and
that i can be really competitive in a
lot of ways and
since competition is an enduring
condition
that must mean that i'm always competing
with everyone
all the time and if i'm always in
competition
well then when do i get a break when do
i sleep
well we're not we're not sleeping or not
a lot obviously but how do i not how am
how am i not getting burnt out
i'm always competing how am i not
getting burned out
and i was thinking about that because i
you know i start to think about people
hearing this and i like to think
through how people are going to
interpret what
i'm saying and dave you and i see this a
lot with just the title of the first
book extreme ownership and people think
extreme ownership will that just mean we
need to be extreme about stuff
and we have to write a whole nother book
how to write a whole nother book with
leif
called the dichotomy of leadership
saying no actually you got to be
balanced we don't want to be extreme
so when i think about talking
and i'm sitting here saying i'm
competing all the time and we're
competing in everything as a competition
and i think of someone going okay well
we're going hard all the time and then
they're going to get burnt out
and how is it that i'm not getting
better am i super human
no i'm just another person so how is it
that i'm competing all the time which i
can tell you i can tell you
honestly i am competing all the time
and i'm also telling you i'm not
superhuman how is this happening
i can explain it the kind of people
that get burnt out and and fall apart
the reason that that happens is because
they are competing at a tactical level
that's what's going on they are getting
caught up in
bar brawls and street fights and
duels and arguments and they want to win
every altercation they see occurring
anywhere around them
and their ego won't let them rest
and i'm not doing that
i don't care about the bar brawl
or the street fight or the argument i
don't care about those things don't care
about them
i'm in competition but i'm not in
competition
at a tactical level i'm competing
strategically
at least i'm trying to right i'm not
perfect i'm trying to compete
strategically do now do do you sometimes
have to win tactical battles
do you sometimes do you have a battle a
tactical battle that you have to win
some people come to me with that
argument you know there's some battles
that you have to win you know what
you're right
and you know what they call those
battles they call them strategic battles
that's not a tactical battle anymore
if i'm in a strategic battle i'm going
to win that
and the point of saying this is as we
talk about competition
and you hear dave and me and echo
getting all fired up about competition
and competing all the time and i keep
saying you're always in competition and
everything's a competition
as we talk about that don't get wrapped
around
tactical competition
think strategic think strategic all the
time
and you know you you should get in some
tactical scraps sometimes
so you don't lose your edge i'm going to
go ahead and say that i'll
you want to get a little scrap we're
going to get a little sparring session
going let's do it
but i'll tell you what i'm not going to
waste any resources
i'm definitely not going to take any
significant damage
look i might get a little dinged up it's
okay but i'm not going to
waste resources real resources
and here's another thing
if you're competing against me
i will have you in tactical fights all
day long
i will put tactical things out there to
distract
you and fight you and i put some minimum
amount of resources against
your whole deal and make you think
you're achieving this big victory and
you're not
i will be watching you take damage i'll
be watching you waste resources
i'll be watching you expend leadership
capital
while i'm putting money in the bank
i'm putting money in the bank and i'm
gonna win
i am going to win
so don't mistake that as we talk through
this manual don't mistake
tactical competition for strategic
competition
and we have been saying you are
competing and you should remember that
you are competing and you are competing
all the time
but you should be competing
strategically
and with that we can go into the book
what do you got dave
bro i'm just over here taking notes um
and i'm
i'm just trying to write down because
i'm taking this home and thinking about
it
he could probably say that again a
tactical battle that you need to win
isn't a tactical battle just thinking of
it in those terms like if you have to
win that battle meaning it's necessary
by definition that's not tactical it's a
strategic thing because if you didn't
if it didn't matter then it's not
strategic if it doesn't matter then who
cares
i just the just the concept of a
tactical battle you need to win
isn't tactical and that even on the
leadership side when people ask the
question hey
where do i hold the line where do i have
to
apply resources or or expend capital
and the idea that even in reverse okay
hey if it has to be
achieved this is not a tactical thing
this is a strategic thing and
understanding that uh again that's just
some of that's just for me to think
about because and then you ask yourself
or you see a client or you see a human
being
treating something as if it's a
strategic battle
and and they don't think through it yeah
they don't see that i mean
really what's the deal what happens
what's the worst case scenario if you
lose that battle
well i'm gonna they're gonna get the
oppo
whatever thing they've rationalized
inside their head
which which is dragging them to expend
resources
to expend leadership capital to make
someone do something
because they're gonna look bad which is
just insanity
it's total insanity there's almost
nothing there's almost
nothing that i need to make one of my
subordinates do
there's almost i can't barely think of
anything that i need to make one of my
subordinates do
you know what i need to make one of my
sports do i need to make sure that all
my subordinates knew how to program
their radios
before they went out by them by when on
an operation in ramadi because if they
got stuck without a radio not knowing
how to program it
they would die so on that
that's you know why you always use that
example
because there's like one of the few that
i can possibly think of
yeah it's one of the few that i can
possibly think of where i was like yeah
you know what you have to do this
now here's why and it's not like i had
to have a big discussion all i said was
hey guys if you can't program your radio
and you get separated
you're going to die therefore you're not
going out
did anyone say well actually i don't
think it's that big for us no everyone
yeah roger that
there was no there was no discussion
about it wasn't like an argument
it was hey guys i should have done a
better job
explaining how easy it is to get
separated in an urban environment and if
you get separated in this environment
the people that will be coming to get
you
they won't be us they'll be an army unit
or a marine corps unit and you'll need
to know how to put those frequencies
into your radio by yourself
otherwise you'll be out there alone and
you'll get captured and you'll have
your head cut off and it takes by the
way
15 minutes to learn how to program a
radio let's get it done and everyone
goes yeah roger that
but there's not too many things that
that that require
that and and like i said even that
didn't require so i that was that didn't
even cost me leadership capital
it didn't it actually that that move
actually didn't cost me leadership
capital
instead people are like yeah man i would
venture to guess that my leadership my
leadership capital went up a little bit
because guys are thinking
[Music]
i didn't really think of that and by the
way this guy cares about me because he
doesn't want me to be stuck
in the middle of ramadi without being
able to communicate
this guy the reason this guy wants me to
do this is because he cares about me
it has nothing to do with my personal
gain
zero what do i get out of it nothing
well i guess i'm taking care of my guys
but again what is that i'm taking care
of my guys
the discrimination between tactical
and strategic is a huge
area for growth for us as human beings
and i think echo this has been your
constant theme since we started
the podcast of the biggest lesson that
you learned was
long term versus short term which is the
civilian way of saying
strategic long-term tactical
short-term and the difference between
those two yes sir and the more you
figured that out
the better your life got yep just like
that
how old were you when we started this
podcast 30
yeah there's people that are listing
this podcast right now that are that are
thinking i'm 32 man i already went no
it's already too late
no no it doesn't matter and
i mean i get messages from people that
are 58
and they say yo i'm starting to look at
this long term and make these
adjustments and here's what i'm going to
do
it's never too late no it's never too
late to start thinking strategic
what's the the expression about
jiu-jitsu like when's the best
time to plant a tree or start your best
time to plant the tree
either 28 years ago right
or today yeah same deal man same exact
exact same deal yep check
all right chapter three it's a short
chapter but there's a lot in it
chapter three is called preparing for
competition so you know how that's gonna
sound
the most important task for marines and
the marine corps
is to recognize that we are always
competing
even choosing to do nothing is a
competitive decision
it just happens to be one that
surrenders the initiative to our
competitors
yes when you choose to do nothing
you are surrendering your the initiative
to your competitor
now i gotta throw a caveat in there
that there are some times where
tactical patience which is the cool way
of saying waiting
is a good thing there's absolutely times
where you want it you want to give
things a second to develop
we used to say that to young seals if
they were making calls too fast
hey let it develop a little bit you
don't even know what's really happening
you've heard
four gunshots and you're trying to make
a decision on which way to go
no let's wait till we hear some volume
of fire from the enemy so we actually
have a more
relevant and real idea
as to where they are
but i think the number is seven out of
ten times
maybe 8 out of 10 times action is better
than inaction
so that's why the marine corps says bias
for action that's why echelon front says
default aggressive it's better to make a
move
out of ten times nine out of ten times
it's better to make a move
and if you have an open mind and you're
gonna read a feedback loop it almost
becomes ten out of ten
and if you're gonna do iterative
decision making meaning i'm gonna make a
small move
really quickly then it becomes a hundred
percent
i'm gonna make a really quick move i'm
gonna then read the feedback loop and
see what i've got
and if you can do that which is what i
do
that's how i cheated that's how i cheat
in decision making
i don't make a big decision why would i
make a big decision make a little one
make a little tiny decision yeah
it does kind of the more you think about
it the more
it becomes like yeah like a 10 out of
10. especially when you think of it in
those terms where
yeah default aggressive not meaning
you're going all out full speed one
direction every single time it's not
that it's like you got to be
because it's kind of comes from my
mindset right
where obviously default aggressive does
but
if taking action versus not taking
action
if you just reduce it just to the
mindset like then you can kind of
understand like oh yeah to not take
action is
with very few if any exceptions the
wrong thing to do
yeah especially when you consider what
action
how small an action can be yes and still
be action
right exactly right yeah yeah because
like has a hesitation right
that's what you don't want the
hesitation that's like in action that's
like
i'm not making any decision to
hold here or or anticipate this i'm not
making a decision i'm just like
hesitating kind of thing
like just not doing nothing yeah when
you think about like immediate action
drills which you'll have
you know in a platoon where if we get
if we get shot at here's the immediate
action is going to happen without
anything there's action happening with
no call being made no decisions been
made but there's action happening
dave i i apologize for not have
that i haven't memorized this immediate
action that you have in a jet
and it's some move that you make when
you don't know what else to do but you
just do it what is it
effector on and pull yes lift vector on
and pull
that's an action yep and that action
you can take that immediately and then
you can figure out what you're going to
do that's right
so it's good to think through those
things it's good if you can if you can
just
if you can just think about if you can
just have an sop or standard operating
procedure that
hey if this happens i know i'm at least
going to do this
that's a really positive thing
yeah i'm i'm racking my brain kind of
trying to think of a time where
doing nothing and and you already said
it i think the thing i was thinking
about is even the smallest move
even the smallest decision that to do
anything
you interact with the environment
somehow and get some feedback you get
something now that something
could be very little and okay cool then
i can move a little bit more but even
the smallest move
gives you something so thinking of it in
those terms it's really hard and i'm
i'm just thinking of an example
we're doing nothing and i can't i can't
think of one
when the alternative is hey make a
really small move
just to see what you get in that
feedback loop just to see what kind of
return you get on that
and even if the return is like all
negative it's such a small move
that the risk of even that 100 negative
feedback is like hey that's good
information
that hasn't toppled us over or crushed
us so even if the response is
all bad the move is so small that's
actually good for you
so i i i just can't piece something
together and go no actually
there here's a time where i really think
doing nothing is right
when the when that is the alternative
we're thinking about right right
and when you when you factor in the
small iterative decisions
it really eliminates a lot of inaction
being good
and and neither one of us and none of us
are saying that that's never the case
but definitely lean towards a bias for
action
definitely lean towards default
aggressive that's where you want to go
and then
lean with little footsteps yeah
and i think we're where people get hung
up on this and we talk about this a lot
the way you describe it it
your iterative decision making the way
you do it happens so quickly and so
rapidly
it appears that you're just going from
here all the way to there so some from
the outside it looks like you're making
these huge moves
and the reason you say you're cheating
is you're gonna i know that's what it
looks like
but that's not what's happening if you
look at it like hey you're going from
here all the way to there
and you're thinking i don't know how to
do that yet so i'm gonna do nothing
if that's your frame of reference i
understand why doing nothing
is is a reasonable alternative what is
what you don't understand is that
you're not doing that you never go from
here all the way to there you have a
thousand little moves along the way
but they happen so quickly and the
maneuvers are so fast that
it doesn't appear like that and and if
that's all you think is oh he just
jocko just goes from here to there
you're like that's actually not
happening
yeah and what's interesting about what
you're saying is
i don't think anyone thinks i'm going
all the way from the here
from point a to point f i don't think
they think that
i think that they don't even know if we
should go to point
f or point z or point y and so they're
just they haven't made
any decision whatsoever meanwhile i go
go to b
that's right you're not saying go to f
i'm not saying go to f i'm saying go to
b
and meanwhile they don't even know where
to go but then i all of a sudden say hey
we're going to be right now and everyone
goes oh damn how did he know to go to b
because b is only a little tiny ways
away but everybody thinks that's a big
move because they were trying to
calculate
they were trying to try to do that
calculus for a giant
and that's what leads to doing nothing
because you can't do that calculus
and by the way what helps you do the
calculus well it helps you do the
calculus when you start filling into the
variables what starts filling in the
variables
is when you start gathering information
and when you start gathering this
information you start filling in those
variables and like you said even if that
variable is negative
and we go oh there's more enemy to the
west okay cool now guess what we know
we're not going west
we can start moving east we can start
moving south whereas if we just sat
there
we still don't know where to go we don't
know they go east west north south we
don't know where to go
yeah so that small movement to the east
hey we just identified more bad guys
okay cool
now we know not to go there
so there's the opening sentence
[Laughter]
competition in the marine corps marines
and the marine corps
are tools for the nation to by the way
you know
i the you know the
the people talk about like what's the
greatest speech that's ever been
delivered you know is it
martin luther king is it is it winston
churchill
is it teddy roosevelt you know we have
nothing to fear but it is which one of
those speeches is the greatest speech
ever and no one's ever asked me this
question in a public forum where i could
answer this question the way i want to
answer this question
but chesty puller
gave a speech at like
some marine corps ball gathering and he
was already retired he was already
chesty puller
and you know he they they call him up to
give the speech that he's gonna give
and the freaking place goes completely
nuts obviously
and he gets up there and he and he
delivers what i believe to be
at least a strong contender at least for
me the greatest speech of all time
and you know what he says
he just says marines
and that's it the place went freaking
nuts
and he walked off the stage
so whenever i see the word marines
i think of that that's all he needed to
say
so marines and the marine corps are
tools
for the nation to use in the enduring
competition that takes place in
international relations
so what does that mean what does that
mean
that means every single thing that you
do
every single thing that you do is
is playing into this competition that
you're in all these different aspects
every day
marine capabilities and force posture
affect the thinking of our competitors
and potential adversaries
again this is to propaganda for the
marine corps
in case me talking about chesty puller
saying marines isn't good enough
propaganda for the record
the more credible the marine corps the
more attractive we
are to allies and partners the more
credit
credible the marine corps is as a
deterrent force the more we affect
potential rivals thinking for marines
petition
participation in our nation's
competitions starts at recruitment
the quality level of individuals brought
into the service provides the raw
material to build a credible force
attributes like education level physical
fitness and mental resilience determine
how quickly these individuals
can be transformed into members of a
coherent
capable organization these attributes
also help establish the range of
possibilities
available to adapt the existing force or
innovate to create a new one
how much do you know about marine corps
recruiting dave
i mean i have my own personal experience
with it i i don't know if i'm an expert
on it but
i have a small sense of how it works the
rumor that i've always heard about the
marine corps
is that the marine corps spends like a
fraction of the amount of money that the
navy the army and the air force spend on
recruiting do you know anything about
that
i don't i can't give you any facts on
that that wouldn't surprise me but i
couldn't prove that
yeah that's what i've always heard i i i
believe
now i know that they must spend some
money because they have advertisements
and they have
you know commercials and stuff like that
but
damn they do a good job based on
narrative alone
i mean my my recollection of when i was
like really getting into
thinking about the marine corps was the
way that
one of the ways i was convinced is it
made it sound like it was probably
impossible
like that recruiting like you're
probably not good enough
yeah but if you are this is where you
should be and there's this sense of like
oh man
now dakota meyer almost the exact same
story
you know he showed up and i forget what
kind of crate he was talking about he
had some crazy like haircut
whatever he was a punk ass kid and he
shows up and says
i want to be in the marine corps and
they said you don't really look like
your marine corps material
now do you think this is when you go to
recruiting school
are they teaching you that as a
recruiter i'm pretty sure that's a
technique that they
they leverage now what's interesting is
jp danelle same thing walked into the
navy recruiter
i want to be a navy seat or i should
probably like i want to be a navy seal
because he's
14 years old or whatever he was and they
said
ah the wannabes need to come in on
thursday wouldn't you want to be
and he was determined to just approve
that freaking recruiter
in sacramento california that that jp
had what it took
it's a great screening tool because i
know the marine corps wants people that
think
that they want they want people that
have big egos in the sense i think they
can do things that are hard
and a great way to test that is hey this
is too hard for you and if you go yeah
you're right
they don't watch anyway what they want
is them to go oh really
so i i i would say i'm pretty sure that
that is a technique that they
proliferate throughout officer and
enlisted recruiting is you're probably
not good enough but
but we'll see now
what percentage of people does that
backfire the humble guy that's a super
stud
that says yeah you know probably him i
guess i'm not just
i'm probably not just cut out for it
and i guess maybe that is a good
self-selection because now we got a dude
that maybe at the moment of truth can't
really believe in his capabilities very
strange
historically the marine corps has been
the nation's hybrid force
[Music]
conducting activities that straddle the
line between violence and non-violence
marines have often deployed two places
to help the local people
in time of need while being ready to
restore order
in those same places if required
the direction for the marine corps to be
the most ready
when the nation is least ready applies
as much to
competition as it does to war and this
is a
another one of these statements where
you think well that that that right
there is a maneuver
to the department of defense to give us
money give you need to allocate
money to the marine corps because when
the nation is least ready the marine
corps will be the most ready
in fact this statement can be viewed as
a competitive act
in the informational element of national
power
next section is called campaigning
mindset
competition is in and i you know i love
the word campaign
why because
because that's the opposite of tactical
battle
that's the opposite of a hack it's the
opposite of a shortcut
it's an opposite of this easy solution
the sweatless solution
as colonel david hackworth once said
it's a campaign campaigns don't happen
overnight
competition is enduring in nature at the
national level
and the military element normally plays
a supporting role especially on the
spectrum
of competition short of war
this leads us to develop a campaigning
mindset about competition which is
characterized by long-term thinking
and recognition that we need to
integrate our actions with others
marines compete as part of a naval and
joint force
but also as part of the inter-agency
in an approach that combines all the
elements of national power
now it's sentences like this where i
think this
this document is not aimed at a lance
corporal this document
is aimed at the dod this is a campaign
this document is a campaign it's correct
but this document is a campaign to make
sure that we keep the marine corps
strong
marines should strive to integrate our
allies and partners into our
competitions as this will increase our
options
while also increasing the potential
number of dilemmas dilemmas we can
present to our rival
our rivals what a and we're going to get
to this
i don't know if it's in this chapter or
one of the later chapters when we start
talking about
one of my favorite military terms the
combined arm
dilemma combined arms dilemma
but when you think about what you're
doing is creating dilemmas for your
rivals
even in not necessarily in a wartime
scenario but even in a competitive
scenario
or a threshold less than violence you're
trying to create
dilemmas for them it's a powerful thing
[Applause]
the cultivation of humility is also
important for this mindset
humility is the most important
characteristic for a leader to have
and even though we just had a little
conversation about the fact that we want
people in the marine corps
that have at least some level of
arrogance you don't think i can do this
watch this
that's why we got to remind them that
the cultivation of humility
is also important for this mindset
marines learn early on
about the observe orient decide act loop
or ooda loop
understanding of uda teaches us that
each decision
is a hypothesis that gets tested in the
real world when we act
lately when i've been talking to clients
in a sp well i shouldn't say lately as
covid kicked off and i would be talking
to clients
i would i had this little uh this little
spiel that i was giving them and and and
basically what i was saying is
hey if you're in a leadership position
and you're not sure what to do
what you got to do in that situation you
got to guess
and i've got then i'd go off about guess
i'd say listen everybody no one wants to
hear the word guess
like hey dave you're in charge what do
you want me to do oh let me take a guess
no one wants to hear that that sounds
horrible
who wants to follow somebody that i
guess we should have you ever heard a
leader in your life that was inspiring
with you with confidence when they said
hey i'm guessing we should go over there
you don't say that as a leader you don't
use those words
and yet and then i follow it up and say
but when you're in a leadership position
when you are making a decision what
you're calling a decision
it is a guess and what the marine corps
did here
because they didn't want to use the word
guess they they sent us up into the next
level and just called it a hypothesis
well that's what that is which is a
guess educated which is an
educated guess which is still a guess
but the amount of times that you are in
a leadership position
where you know for certain what's gonna
happen next is
point zero zero zero one percent because
we can't predict the future
we don't know what all these little
variables are how all these little
variables are gonna turn out
so that's what we're doing as leaders is
we're making
guesses we're making hypotheses we're
taking what you say educated guesses
that's like in between right a guess is
just a guess an educated guess next
level hypothesis
yes sir yep
so we've got to understand that we
understand that that decision is a
hypothesis that gets tested in the real
world when we actually act
the campaigning mindset then includes
the understanding
that we base our plans on a model we
created of our competitor
okay our decisions about how to achieve
our goals and competition
are theories they're guesses
a lot of guesswork going on
and what's good what i like about using
the word guess
what i like about that is i think you
know
dave you were talking earlier about
hesitation if you're making a
decision-making process
well if i'm a young leader and i'm
looking at my options a b
or c and i'm not sure which one to do
i might be thinking in my mind well what
am i supposed to just guess
am i supposed to just take an educated
guess with what we should do right now i
got all these resources i got maybe
lives at stake or i got capital at stake
i got all these things going on
i don't feel comfortable just guessing
so i'm just going to sit here
i'm just going to sit here and and wait
because i'm scared
because i it doesn't seem right that i
should be guessing what to do
yes you should now what i recommend you
do
is you guess little
just take a little guess hey should i go
indoor a b or c
you know what i'm gonna do immediately
hey i'm gonna walk up that door and take
a listen what do i hear in there
right is there a party going on or is
there gun fire
so or is there no noise now no noise i'm
a little scared about but if i hear
music
that's kind of a positive sign but i
didn't enter the door
all i did was put my ear up to it so
that's what you do you make a little
guess
i guess we should check out that door i
hear gunfire that doesn't sound like a
good door
what about the next door i hear nothing
not sure about that one
what about this door over here i hear
music
i hear um uh music that echo charles
plays in his vehicle
from the islands which means everyone in
that room is kind of cruising
and i'm feeling pretty good about it
we're opening that door no factor
so if you're not comfortable taking the
guess
then it's hard to make a decision
our plans then need to have feedback
loops built into them
to either confirm that our models and
theories are correct enough
to help us reach our goals or that we
need to modify them
and by the way they don't bring this
back up to humility
they should because if you're not humble
and you think i'm guessing door c and
you walk up to it you hear gunshots
you're like well i guess c we're going
in
bad idea so it takes humility to modify
your plan and if you're not humble you
won't be modifying your plan you'll be
sticking with your plan until it
kills you
competition campaigning introduces the
idea of persistence
strategic competition is more like a
marathon than a sprint
competition's enduring nature means that
any
campaign will require long-term
commitment to achieve its goals
we also need to be alert for how our
competitive advantages
and those of our rivals will shift over
time
this is what's scary about
wars like iraq afghanistan vietnam
where your enemy is home
they're not on deployment they're going
to be there
and when the wars they'll wait they'll
they'll be there for a hundred years
there's not an american that wants to be
there there's not an american that's
hey i'm stoked i'm in al qaeda
hey i'm stoked i'm in cut hey i'm stoked
wherever they want to be
back in nebraska they want to be
back in iowa but the people that we're
fighting against
they're they are home so before you get
into that
combat you got to figure out who's got
the home field advantage
it's a big deal it's a way bigger deal
than it is in sports
this next section is professionalism
as military professionals charged with
the defense
of the nation marine leaders must be
true experts in the conduct of war
this statement from war fighting one
the the mcd p one war fighting
establishes
the first priority for marines which is
defend the nation
as professionals marines recognize this
defense as a vital and
enduring national interest our
professionalism is grounded in our
nation's values
which sets us apart from our from from
competitors
achieving that standard being prepared
to defend the nation
has been and will continue to be a
competitive act
so us just being ready is is is how we
are helping america compete with
everybody else in the world because they
got to keep
up you see what the marine corps is
doing you know you better be training
hard
we accept that the existence of the
marine corps helps deter
potential foes our goal is for that
deterrence to take place
below the violence threshold
so what we're doing right there we're
kind of making sure that
even the doves in the government are
looking at the marine corps thinking
you know the marine corps doesn't want
war either
the marine corps wants peace they want
it they want these things to happen
below the we better give them more money
well-funded marine corps professionals
understand
this goal and thus direct their energies
self-study and unit development
in particular toward achieving it
so all marines are trying to become
professionals professionals
true experts in the conduct of war
as professionals we recognize that
development of coercive tools must be
balanced with the need to attract
in competition as well for example one
component of an attraction strategy
could lead to greater deterrence through
building increased interoperability with
an ally
it could also lead to advances through
the informal element of national power
as we perform
disaster relief mission marines must
remain alert for the opportunities to
use and integrate both coercion and
attraction into the larger competition
so the marine corps is not they're
saying here we're not just here to fight
wars
we're here to build relationships now at
echelon front we talk about building
relationships all the time
that's what that's how you lead you lead
by building relationships that's how you
get things done by building
relationships
and what we're talking about here is we
are competing
and in order to compete guess what we do
we build relationships we build
relationships
and just to give people example and i'm
sure you have some more dave but
especially before the war started for me
in the 90s
this is what the seal teams did go to a
country train
their special operations unit do a big
exercise
train them in the use of our weapons we
train in the use of their weapons we
send some people to learn how to speak
their language we bring some people to
learn
that they can learn how to speak english
we form these relationships we work
together
so that way we're strengthening our
allies we have somebody we can rely upon
we get to know them but that's just
relationships that's what it is did you
guys do that in the
in the pilot world yeah i mean i'm
thinking about carrier deployments and i
think right now there's a connotation
that the aircraft carrier and it's
probably already
always existed but certainly now since
you know post 911
the carrier is this power projection
tool this
you know the um uh you know 90 000 tons
of diplomacy you know
sovereign u.s soil all over they have
these great tag lines the navy
leverages which which are true in a lot
of ways but pre-911 if you ever did a
cruise pre-911 like i did back in the
day
the joke though we called them pleasure
cruises it was like 13 14 port calls
and the two months you know that you you
sailed from san diego to to the persian
gulf
was a bunch of port calls you're you're
doing joint operations with different
countries you're you're
pulling up piercing contributing to
their economy you're building all those
relationships and most of it is allies
or people we want to build relationships
with then you go to the gulf for a
couple months do that thing
and in that you're doing three or four
protocols to bahrain to the uae all
these places we're trying to strengthen
relationships and that
that to carrier was an instrument of
power projection it was an instrument of
diplomacy
which was building those relationships
obviously post 911
you know my experience my second cruise
was like go to the north arabian gulf
stay there for seven months come home
but you know before that
the investment that navy was making was
mostly strengthening the relationships
and there are stories out there even
somewhat recently that
carriers would deploy for disaster
relief with no aircraft on them just to
send a carrier to help
you know floods and and crazy things
that happen in different places
strictly for strengthening ties and
relationships
that are projecting literal no combat
power by design because the navy sea
well i'm sure it's larger than just the
navy but that's my connection and you
know i deployed off carriers for the
most part
so that's attraction right that's that's
that's attraction
as opposed to deterrence right we're
just trying to show people that hey
we're you want to be friends with us
yeah
we're attractive we can help you if you
get no time and need we're a good ally
at a tactical level when i would deploy
in the 90s
we would go out and do exercises where i
would be
in the jungle with
some special operations unit from some
other country
what do you do when you are a
fighter pilot same thing are you giving
them a tour are you taking them in the
back seat
like at a tactical level just out of my
own curiosity
what would you do you're you're flying
with them you're spending time with them
and
and there's a little bit wait are they
flying their aircraft and so you're
they're your wingman and you work so
yeah integrating with them sometimes you
fight against them sometimes you fight
with them
really what it's supposed to be is you
ever put your ego in check and let one
of these
what let one of these foreigners be beat
you in a dog fight
no dude come on man zero percent chance
zero now certain countries
they would have we would fly with
different countries that they would have
different roe different rules
uh training rules and things like that
and you could see some of them were
geared very specifically to make sure
that certain people had advantages
and we would play by those rules and and
sometimes get in trouble for not
following those rules
uh you know one of the things that's
really cool about the american military
and certainly in aviation and there's a
saying we have is like hey there's no
rank in the cockpit
so i could be the junior doing the
squadron i'm not saying this happened
very often but you could be a mid-level
guy you're going to go out flight with
your boss
and once you start fighting him like you
can pummel him to just
pummel him into the ground and it's it's
there is no like defense like i don't
want to make the old man look bad you
you go out there and do your thing
um that's not always like that but the
the interaction
in some sense was this idea that this
american military with this big might
this big power our aviation world is is
something they can learn from but we
always learn stuff from them too we
would share briefing techniques and how
they ran their briefs how they trained
their guys how they did certain things
and a lot of it at least on paper was
for us to bring to them
things that could help them get better
but it was always reciprocal we always
learn from operating with other
countries and i flew
with pilots and airplanes from all sorts
of different countries even sometimes
the same exact airplane
but they fly it differently they do
things differently so there's a whole
bunch of things that you can do to
interact with them that is beneficial
for both
it was probably lopsided what we knew
and how we did it was usually more
more beneficial to them but it wasn't
completely one-sided either
flying dissimilar with different
countries is a blast because you learn
stuff and go oh man
we don't do that in our airplanes that's
really good for me to see it makes me
more prepared for
if something actually really happens
would you guys go toe-to-toe top gun
dogfight style one-on-one yeah you'd
have a you'd have different things
i've never been in a situation where if
the brief was you and me are gonna fight
i don't care what country or what plane
once fights on it is game on there is no
like hey go easy on this guy or let this
guy
i have never been in a dogfight once in
my life other than hey i'm there to show
you certain things
but if it's like a real dog fight like
just a real
fight you're just you fly your best
airplane
there are times that you would dial back
your best
jet because it'd be really it would
undermine
the effectiveness of the training of the
relationship building as well
but it's never to like oh you did you
were eating
really caught me off guard there yeah
yeah you got me
that would be that would be you know in
in the heyday of ken when you're
a top gun ip and you're fighting against
you know somebody else and you're gonna
come back
no joke you come back with 25 30 valid
shots
that can be really disheartening for
somebody to look on paper and go hey let
me see your shot card and they've got
zero shots
and you're like oh hang on i need to get
my second sheet of paper
and if there's a topkin ip or a website
ip listen to this they're laughing right
now because
you can come back with in four or five
sets five six shots per and you have
30 valid shots and the other guys got
zero if you do that set
after set after set after set after a
while it'd be like you and me
rolling on the mats and you doing
nothing but trying to beat me you're not
teaching me you're not training me
you're just going to beat me like
bro i don't want to do this anymore so
you would dial that back but you'd never
be like oh dave
that was amazing how you did that i i
didn't think you could you would never
get to that level of that in
an actual fight when we're training and
doing other things yeah you
you're there to learn and they they
learn from you learn from them but i've
never been in a 101
1v1 where i'm dialing it back because
somebody needs
you know somebody's saying hey don't
don't fight your best gem i'm only doing
that
you know in a tactical sense of helping
him see sight pictures and maneuvering
in a way that's benefiting him
uh but not like because i feel bad or
something like that
are the personalities of the foreign
countries
fighter pilots similar to americans
yeah one other thing too and i i'd be
interested in what you saw with special
forces around the world
what i came to find is despite what
appears to be a whole bunch of
differences between different countries
when it came down to it
the personalities of fighter pilots are
really similar there are differences
there are some cultural things there's
some organizational things but at the
end of the day
fighter pilots that fly fighters in any
country and every type any type of
fighter
they're much more similar than they are
different yeah same thing with
special operations they'd have there's
definitely some some differences in
culture and whatnot but
it's it's a pretty thin pretty thin
layer
that you have to pull back and all of a
sudden oh these guys are kind of just
like us
the mentality totally yeah from a
maintenance perspective
it seems like just the american sort of
from manufacturing to like maintenance
the maintenance programs in the navy you
know
even in the seal teams we would
especially
before the once the war started we kind
of we we
saw less of the navy kind of
administrative stuff
right on our in inside the terms
but when the 90s it was like hey you got
to do these protocols that the big navy
follows and
and so you'd see oh well you know these
guys are squared away the navy
is squared away there's a reason that
when you
when you pull a piece of firefighting
gear off of a
wall on a ship that's been there for
three years
it works it works because it's gone
through this maintenance check it's gone
through every 30 days and every 90 days
it's gotten this it's got this that the
other thing
is are there are do foreign countries
have that same
level of uh being squared away from a
maintenance perspective
you know i don't know i i don't know if
i ever got to that level
that layer of fidelity i will say
that the american military certainly the
navy and the marine corps
i get most of my experience with that is
something we take
really really seriously and what you
just described is
the equipment that we have the things we
have as old as they are whatever the
things that we have
work and that when i manned up an
aircraft
i never once got in an airplane and felt
like kind of sketchy about it
never once did i get an airplane and not
feel like i'm getting an airplane and
i'm not sure
i'm not sure if that's true for for
other countries or other other services
well outside of america but i always and
i've flown with the navy a lot i've won
the marine corps a lot i found the air
force a lot and that is
universal okay so i have a different
feeling and i have gotten into aircraft
and been completely sketched out with
both my fingers crossed hoping that this
thing is going to make it
and in all those cases it wasn't a it
was in an aircraft that was not an
american military aircraft when you're
going
well i guess this is we could go down
like that this could be it
i never had the best feeling and what's
weird is
you know the the other thing about the
american military
aircraft is there working man like the
navy helicopters
they're great they're just they're it's
you know what they are they're daily
drivers
they're a daily driver a a ch-46
a navy ch-46 that thing is a daily
driver that thing is a ford
f-150 that's just ready it's
that thing is going to do its job so i
always felt even though there'd be
hydraulic fluids all over the deck and
it would
it would be a little bit it would look
sketchy
but you're you know that that thing's
been flying well first how old is the
ch-46 platform
19 early 1960s
and some of those birds are from the
1960s still flying
well at least they were still flying
when when i was in
yeah all right little tangent right
there
and what's interesting is everything we
just talked about
all plays that's what this whole book is
about it's about competition but it's
all those things that's the reason i was
kind of diving into it it's all these
things are
how we are competing with our
allies and with our rivals and we're
letting everybody know that this is what
we've got and these are capabilities and
this is what we can do
like that's all part of the game yeah
and i was thinking that
that that tangent was also like that's
what makes us professionals that's the
profession of what we're doing
it's not a it's not a it's not a hobby
it's fun as it is it's
it's flying airplanes all those are
professional things and that's
when we were uh working with other
countries
the one thing i will say this is that i
know when you were going to fight
someone outside of your squadron
so another squadron and then outside of
the service like we're gonna go with the
air force
you you had the sense of like hey you
gotta you gotta be on your a-game when
we were fighting with other countries
it was like you you are gonna show them
your absolute
best game in everything we do from brief
to shut down and everything in between
so there was a sense of looking the part
and that ev
every step away from your squadron from
your bros that went up higher like don't
you go fight with the air force and
embarrass us
and when you're fighting you know
working with foreign countries the
need to look professional was absolutely
understood
verbalized at all or no absolutely
absolutely absolutely
jack who would you train with like for
example like what what other country
let me i mean okay so i have trained
personally with
canadians australians brits saudis
emiratis kuwaitis singapore malaysia i'm
i'm running out there's more
these are all just air forces or
services your countries that fly
different airplanes or interacted
in some way um japan a
whole bunch of countries do you ever fly
their planes
so every you said something i'm kind of
laughing at it
and i didn't know we're going to circle
back to it every single time you go do
this kind of the last day or two you
have some graduation thing and they're
always offering
hey you jumping and i remember i flew
single-seat airplanes so
it wasn't always that we could do that
but if there's a two-seat jet or
something we always offering and they're
always offering us hey jump in the back
seat
i never once never once i don't want to
be in the back seat
first of all of anything certainly not
of a you know a former
soviet union mig-29 that's you know
wow i never got in the backseat of
somebody else's airplane you were busy
couldn't do it that day not available um
and that i think is what you're saying
like
i don't know anything about any of these
i don't know about this airplane and
yeah first of all i don't want anything
in the back seat
i don't know if the cool and guys would
guys would kill for that stuff
and i never wanted to do it but you know
back of a flanker or a mig or something
go for it dude that's all you yeah
sometimes you'd have the same planes
though right
or no yeah canadians australians will
see the exact same airplanes
it's the like in the seal teams if
you're going to do something
in some foreign aircraft the only way to
get out of it would be to
basically quit
you know you can't say like well hey
guys i'm not really comfortable with
this aircraft
and so you're sitting there in a squad
and every single one of those probably
like there's
every single one of those guys is
thinking we should not be doing this
and every single one of those guys
doesn't say a word about it gets on that
bird and goes and does what you got to
do
not me
uh back to the book war fighting also
instructs
that the quote military profession is a
thinking
profession end quote this means that
marines must practice
mental the mental discipline necessary
to challenge our assumptions
as professionals we need to
dispassionately assess the environment
and make certain we are setting the pace
for our competitors i was on with a
client the other day and
well you know the lead-in to the
question that i got asked was well you
know in the in the military of course
it's a
it's a very hierarchy uh
structured thing and what you want is
people that all think the same way
you know that was the lead into the
question so then he asked the question
then i had to start with well let me
just tell you that the last thing i want
on my team is a bunch of people that
think the same way i do
actually i want a bunch of people that
push back and think different thoughts
and see different perspectives than me
and so here's the marine corps quoting
from their
their their manual number one which is
called warfighting military profession
is a thinking profession
and it takes discipline to challenge our
own assumptions
again it's totally the
it's the complete opposite of what
everyone thinks the marine corps is
everybody thinks everyone
oh we want every marine to think the
same no you don't we want them to
actually
it's actually we're being instructed to
challenge our own assumptions
yeah i like that connection too you were
talking earlier about wanting to see
this thing
connect back to humility which was that
sentence kind of started this and
that there is there is an undeniable
connection there the mental discipline
necessary to challenge our own
assumptions the
humility that it takes to go and look at
your
own guess your own assumption and go
i might be wrong the humility inside of
that
and they're calling it mental discipline
but those two are
completely linked and even if you just
think about the things you say that the
self-discipline it takes
for you to do the things that you do as
disciplined as you are the reason you do
it is that
you don't want to get complacent you
don't want to get comfortable you don't
want to get weak so
you have the mental discipline to do
that and that is that is humility
because if you don't have you're like i
can skip a day i can skip a couple days
whatever
either either a lack of mental
discipline or a lack of humility
will lead you to not challenge your
assumptions and just think that
everything's going fine and we'll just
go through with it my plan's good to go
yeah next section is education
but before before we go into this next
section let me ask you this
do you remember when i was talking about
diving and not wanting to be the buddy
we yeah totally so that was i think when
we were talking about and i was just you
know the single seat
mindset of of my experience you know
this is this is it a similar thing where
if you're in the back seat you're just
kind of not
in control and you're not much to do and
you're sort of
yeah i mean that was for me and
there were guys just like me that had no
problem sitting in the back seat
if if if you lined up like 10 fighter
pilots today
like hey do you want to go fly in the
back seat of an authentic
p-51 from world war ii nine of them
would be in there like this and i would
say no thanks so it could even be 100
or 99 of them would say i'll be in there
just about everything i want to get in
there
i'm not even a freaking pilot yeah and
and i understand that
the historical significance of it and
i'm not
even sure it's rational to even think
that
but i i never ever ever
even even wanted to fly a two-seat
airplane i didn't want to do that
because i didn't i didn't want people
looking at me like hey what are you like
i got this you know and
that that's all young stuff i mean i
think i've grown that in some ways but
there is an absolute menta a uniqueness
of being alone in an airplane there's a
there's a there's something about that
there's something unique about that you
know i got a big smile on my face right
now
so there's a um
i i i'm not even 100 sure about this but
i'm 99.
and this is why i described every time
you say single seat
every time you're like well it's a
single seat there's a
i there's a ferrari sports car
which is one of the most expensive
ferraris that you can get
it's nuts you know it's got 10 million
horsepower and it can do the whatever
and it's a single seat
car and i we're gonna i'm gonna have to
fact check this
the name of the car
is ego east
that's the name it's like something it's
like something ego
that's the name of the car totally i'm
in this thing
by myself there's not even anyone else
to come in here it's not possible this
is all about
me well think of the ego i mean if you
want to
think about even just me think of the
ego of um
flying from the military not good enough
flying helicopters not good enough
flying cobras not good enough
flying jets not good enough flying f-18s
not good enough flying single-seater
f-18s
okay that'll do like the criteria of
what i had created in my mind of
what success was like what success was
was just that and and i don't
i don't mean to like presume that i know
what you you know what you were thinking
but hey do you want to just be in the
navy that's not enough for me
uh you could be a a diver or like and
you could go through the criteria like
and even and i'm i'm implying like it's
kind of crazy like green beret
that's not what i want to do like
joggo you know how many people would
kill to say their green bridge like
yeah you know i understand it but that's
not what i want and
i had created a scenario in my mind like
if it's not a single seat hi-lot
f-18 in the marine corps i'm not gonna
be happy which is kind of
it's insane it's crazy but that is
that is what that's what i wanted to do
and i don't maybe if i ended up in a
two-seat squadron would i somehow go hey
you know what i was an idiot this was
this is totally awesome this is great
maybe but
you want you know the ego the power of
the ego going
and that's i think not to defend myself
too much but
i think it's a little bit different than
arrogance
the ego and the arrogance you know the
flaunting of i'm better than you air
against the more like
no that to me is the hardest that's the
highest peak you can get to
that's where i want to be and i had
created it that
that's what i wanted and other guys like
they didn't care i'll fly whatever
oh really yeah yeah cool whatever i'll
fly that
cool go go fly that
if you don't have that how far do you
make it
not where i wanted to go i mean okay so
there might be some small
tiny minuscule part of the population
that is just so talented
that they can kind of just cruise by and
they're going to get it right
yeah there are and there's some people
that are like guess what i'm doing this
weekend
i'm sharpening my knife i'm polishing my
boots yeah that was me in seal training
you know me and teal training was oh
guys are gonna go to whatever
you know go to the mall go try and meet
girls or whatever i'm gonna sharpen my
knife
the whole weekend right and get ready
for inspection
because i want to make sure i get
through this thing because i'm not sure
i see pitfalls all over the place and i
don't need any more pitfalls than
they're already in existence
and you're not going to feel like you're
missing out either you're not like man i
wish i was out at the bar or at the
club like you're not thinking that at
all you're like this is what i should be
doing that's what i should be doing i
don't care about anything else
so you don't even feel like you're doing
it even though you don't want to
you wouldn't want to do anything else as
a matter of fact if you did the other
thing you're like you know what i should
be doing right now
i should be back home prepping that's
what i should be doing
so the the i think that's the difference
well maybe not the difference but when
you talk about when you talk about
ego and you cross-section some humility
in there
guess what that equals that equals
someone that's working as hard as they
possibly can and holding themselves the
highest possible standards so that they
can achieve
what they want to achieve when someone's
just arrogant
guess what they don't do that extra
studying they don't stay and sharpen
their knives they don't
and and look there's a tiny minuscule
percentage chance that
they have the natural talent and it's
probably well
it's i'll tell you it's a lot easier
in the sea to get through basic seal
training just based on the fact that
you're a really good athlete
and you're decently tough and if you
have that
you can be pretty arrogant and still
make it through because you don't really
need to do anything extra because
you can do a rope climb and you can
carry a log around and it's like okay
you know you played
whatever you you did track and field and
you played football and
you you know you show up and you're 21
years old and you're in really good
shape
you can be pretty arrogant and not
really have to do anything extra and
make it through the program
i bet that's a little bit more
challenging there's probably less people
that would fall into that category
in pilot school because you get hit with
the academics
you get hit with the the fine motor
skills
you get hit with uh the the natural
ability to like i remember when i took
the
test for officer candidate school and
they're showing you pictures and
what is this is this plane they show
like yeah i wasn't even
yeah i wasn't even going into aviation
or anything they're showing you a plane
is this thing coming or going
is this that and so you're getting hit
with those kind of tests as well so
there's got to be there's
there's there's different types of
screening that's taking place
that are more there's a there's a
broader modality of screening as opposed
to seal training it's like
be cold do pull-ups that's
that's not a huge how much autonomy
do you have over your schedule and stuff
in in seal training as well
i'm sure at some point you have zero but
do you have a bunch of free time
do you surprisingly what's surprising to
a lot of people is you do have a lot
yeah you do have a decent amount of free
time
and that is part of the test because
part of the test is oh you want to go
get drunk and get in a fight cool you're
not here anymore right because you just
got in trouble
we don't need you in the seal teams oh
you did you just went
and didn't prepare this weekend and now
you're failing your third inspection
cool we don't need you in the seal team
sec so there is a they have to give you
some
opportunity they have to give you enough
rope that you can hang yourself and you
certainly can and there's plenty got
plenty of guys that did
yeah plenty of guys that got in trouble
in town
didn't come back from mexico in time for
muster and
you know you hit a couple of those
things and you're gone so they give you
enough rope if you're a knucklehead
you'll hang yourself with it
but other than that
if you can do pull-ups and you can
suffer you can do some rope climbs like
you can kind of just grit through it
and that's why i think you that's why i
think
i would venture to say that we have a
higher percentage of arrogance
in the seal teams because you don't
because you're not going to get humbled
quite as much as
as you are in such a selective
scenario as going to flight school well
going to ocs going to the basic school
you know getting down selected down
selecting to get in
down selected at ocs down selected
at the basic school down selected at
flight school
and then down selected to go to top gun
like that's that's a bunch of
very narrow very narrow
funnels that you got to get through if
you're going to make it all the way to
top gun instructor we don't
that's that's a bunch of very narrow
things to pass
yeah even with that it's not a flawless
system
i mean even with that there are guys
that are that are there that maybe
shouldn't be there
i i
i equate and i'm probably wrong about
this it's just my perception i equate
the seals being a navy seal is as
even inside the community of these
highly highly capable special operations
organizations throughout the different
services
that the seals i elevate them in my own
mind that there's just something
unique about that and if i take a step
back and i think like okay flying f-16s
with the air force or flying f-18s for
the navy the marine corps
look man it's the same and there's
probably people say hey green beret and
abc like
you could account a couple of that are
that's not what i had in my mind that
there was a piece that would just set up
a tiny bit
compared to everything else that's what
i think when i think from the outside
of seals or at least can understand
someone in your shoes going
that one and i would say when i was 18
and i was raising my right hand to
enlist in the navy that's what i was
thinking
once i was in and i work with the i work
with the marine corps i work with the
army special force i work with the total
soldiers from the 101st airborne i
realize there's guys here that are 10
times better than me
and they're they're in a ground pounder
in an infantry unit yeah
good i am a humble person i was going to
ask you so what keep
once you make it through wicket after
wicket after after
narrow wicket after narrow wicket after
narrow wicket and now you're at a point
where you're a top gun
senior instructor and there's no person
that can beat you
in a dog fight how are you
finding your humility at that point
for me it was that there actually still
were people that could beat me got it
and i think it was almost luck
that i was able to keep being reminded
of that
and what i mean by that is
no one i will never even if you could
track it i will never be considered
the best even the guys at my top end of
my generation i'm in a conversation of
of a couple of guys but nobody's gonna
go oh dave burke was the best guy
nobody's gonna say that i i simply was
not now i was good enough
to be in a strata of a couple people
that we had a small pool of
of of instructors that sort of fit in
that little category and i was in there
but no question that i was not at the
top is there a singular person that was
or is it too no it's it's usually not
in my experience it was like there's a
little group but inside that every now
and then
those guys get to fight each other and
what almost always happen is it's
at the end it's neutral you come back it
was awesome but nobody got really the
upper hand every now and then you go
dude he was pushing me around a little
bit so he but it's never like he shot me
or he was
pushing me bullying me he was like ah
you had like 10 degrees on me there at
the end of that
20-minute fight so it was really super i
went out towards the later half of my
career i was the i was the senior
instructor talking i was the training
officer as a marine so you're talking
wicked after wicked after wicked i went
out and flew with a guy named trim
downing
legendary navy pilot ceo of top gun my
boss at the time
and he went out and we did four fights
first three word just how you play out
neutral neutral neutral i was paying
really close attention
i got to the last fight and i i did the
first turn and go i'm gonna get him i
got him i figured him out
and it was gonna be a really satisfying
moment for me
and he ended up doing something i didn't
think it could even be done and he
he completely pummeled me and to the
point that i'm looking over my shoulder
almost like a brand new guy going
what what is happening how did this
happen to me
and you know he's laughing at me on the
radio
and not only will i forget it those are
the things that
at just the right intervals in my career
right when i was about to go over the
edge of
i'm unbeatable i'm better than everybody
i never got to that point because
something would always happen and go
and i would go oh damn that guy
is better than me trim did that to me at
a time where had
had that not happened i just didn't
fight against him there's some risk that
i could have just
left there and gone off the deep end and
looked back and go i was the best pilot
in the world which is a
ridiculous thought i was lucky that at
every interval where i got right to the
edge
something would happen to me and go dude
that guy is better than you
and it happened just enough now
that doesn't happen to a lot of people
and
what do you mean that doesn't what
doesn't the the the reminder there are
people that manage to get through and
not
have that experience happen and and
the irony is that there's there's
there's more humility at top gun
than you would think because it keeps
happening when you get stratified in an
organization like top gun
that is humbling because everybody gets
there for the same reason
you get there because you are the best
and then you get there
and then you kind of start stratifying
inside that
and that little tier that i was talking
about that little line and then the
three or four
everybody knows who those guys are
everybody
especially if you're not one of them and
that
that is that is a humbling thing in and
of itself
and if you make it up there the only
risk is if you kind of believe it like
oh i'm here because i'm better than
everyone
if you don't get beat at some interval
that's where you can kind of go hey i
have done something that nobody else can
i've made it to a place that nobody else
can make
that fight against trim you could call
him right now and he would he would
know exactly what i'm talking about
because he also knew it from the he had
been
this was his third time on the staff as
an instructor he'd been there three
times
he had seen it all and the crazy part
about that
was where the first three fights are set
up i don't think so
i really don't i think the setup for him
was
the third the second merge of the fourth
fight
where i looked over i'm like uh he's
slow he can't make this
turn he can't do this maneuver i'm gonna
i can draw it out i
unload and i said he doesn't have the
airspeed to fly
over the top he can't do a loop in this
case
the difference was as my threshold for
loop air speed which was really
low his was lower than mine
and that's something why because of his
aircraft because of his
because of his skill skill his ability
to fly so i'd have
we'd have a thing called so you could do
like for instance you could do a loop in
a half a mile and he could do one in
it's more of speed but yeah so we had a
thing called min vertical air speed we
would teach guys below 150 knots
you cannot go over the top you can't
loop your jet we did that to keep people
from
you know spinning airplanes out of
control my min vertical air speed was
way lower than that like what are you
not allowed to talk about no no i mean
at this point i'm good probably i don't
know 115
100 you can milk it up 120 and and
his because he was a better pilot than
me
he was able to fly his airplane closer
to the edge of
being out of control than i was and i
did my math of
nobody can do that i can't do that so
and i got right to my
my men vertical air speed he was slower
than me which meant i actually had an
advantage over him
i had more speed than him probably 10
knots over him so these are really fine
margins
but that 10 knot differential didn't
affect him as much as it affected me so
when i went up and
i literally looked this way thinking
he'd be falling off you look to the left
and and he wasn't there and i'm like
where else could he be
and he was actually inside my turn above
me and
i'm part of it thinking like you
physically can't do that like
you physics won't allow that the only
thing that allows and and you remember
dan pederson talking about flying the
airplane beyond the capabilities that's
what i was thinking
and the end of it the simplest way to
describe it that guy was a better pilot
than i was
he could do something in his machine
that i couldn't do the exact same
machine
and the outcome was he wins not like
a little advantage it was a lopsided
one-sided at the end was he's directly
behind me
laughing at me if you can't get some
humility from that
and go oh okay i've made it all the way
up here and there's still
someone better than me and thank god
those things happen to me jocko like
thank god that happened to me
because i can kee i take that with me
and and i keep that
and that was a really good lesson for me
had that been reversed
who knows man uh yeah general boyd
when dan pederson was talking about the
fact that he went to the conference in
general
boyd was talking who is the you know and
he's saying look this is what the
aircraft doing we can do it we can
calculate more
and all the top gun guys are going we
can do things that are beyond that
that's right
and what that reminds me of is you'll be
doing jiu jitsu with someone
and they'll have some capability that's
not normal
the two capabilities that might not be
normal one is flexibility
someone someone that's massively
flexible and you
you get past their guard and you think
you're past their garden there's no
human that's going to be able to take
the leg and put it back in front of you
and yet they do it or someone that's
just psycho
strong and you get a cross side on them
and
they kind of bridge and get a position
with their hands and you go what are you
going to do push me off
they push you off of them and that's
pretty freaking
crazy but it's a similar thing that
there's no possible way you think
there's no human that's going to put
their leg in front of me right now
jeff glover jeff glover like you're past
his guard and all of a sudden there's a
leg coming you know over your side and
you're thinking yeah who
is there someone else on the mat with us
right now because a human can't do this
well he's doing it right now and he's
got your back
yeah and the other thing i was i was
thinking about was i was
on my first deployment to iraq and we
were doing a bunch of ops and look at
this point
i was very lucky because there wasn't a
lot of people that we were the only
platoon
in iraq at this time for a short period
of time i had the only platoon in iraq
and we were plused up with some people
but i had the oh
imagine that imagine that all the seals
i have the only platoon in iraq
so it's freaking awesome and i remember
and then eventually you know now the
other platoon started coming in when my
other platoon started coming in
my commanding officer came in and
you know we had a really good
relationship i'd worked for him before
and we had done we had done a series of
operations
rapid operations really tight turn times
and gotta you know got the targets we
were going after
and i remember my commanding officer he
gave me some like
incredibly strong compliment
you know like i mean now it sounds
completely ridiculous
at the time it was this you know really
strong compliment about
what incredible you know groundbreaking
and all this stuff
and i looked at him i remember i looked
at him i said hey sir give me 24 hours
and i'll screw it up
because and the reason i said that is
because on all these operations you're
like
man so many things can go wrong
bad things can happen and
and i don't even you know and we had
already had some bad things happen you
know we'd already had some mistakes we
already had some things that should have
gone different and maybe they didn't
quite leak out to
you know maybe we kept them inside the
platoon like hey dude what were you
doing
why were you over there if we would have
you know if we didn't deconflict at that
moment you could have got shot like
like some things where we we we got away
with it right we got away with some
mistakes
and so he's telling me what a great job
and i just looked at him acer give us 24
hours and i'll screw it up and
and that to me is something i always
tell myself you know
always have that always have that uh
that that person whispering in your ear
telling you that all glory is fleeting
because it is i think that lesson
is it's impossible to say how important
that is
and and you probably know this but every
single day at
work at echelon front no matter what
good work we've done no matter what
impact we made no matter what the client
tells me how great echelon front is
every single new phone call every single
every time i do the same thing i've done
100 times i think about that
i and that that event i was talking
about in the airplane
that's why i think like that and i i
think like that
every single time every single day i'm
about to start off a keynote
that i've done a hundred times or 400
times and i think oh
well you don't want to screw this up you
got to get this right
you you you can undo all the work that
you've done
by not having this be as good as every
other one that you do so
there's so much value in that that
recognition and
for me being reminded that at my best
there's still somebody better
that that i that i keep with me
every single day every day and
everything that i do
so losing is sometimes a good thing
check uh
we're about to jump into the next
section before i went down that tangent
education
and by the way we're on page six now out
of this chapter or something
we're moving right along professional
military education for marines intends
to develop
creative thinking leaders in a
continuous
progressive process of development those
are some words that people do not think
of when they think of the united states
marine corps or the military at large
creative thinking leaders in a
continuous progressive process of
development
this philosophy aligns well with the
kind of education marines need to
succeed in competition as well as in war
while the nature of competition endures
over extended periods
like war its character constantly
evolves
rivals continually strive to improve
their competitive advantages
strive to gain the initiative and strive
to keep
their competitors off balance
if you wake up in the morning and you
just read that line to yourself
that your rivals are continually
striving to improve their competitive
advantages they're striving to gain the
initiative and they're striving to keep
you off of balance
that's a good thing to wake up to in the
morning
because it's real easy to forget that
education is a primary method
for marines to sustain competitive
advantage over time
i'm going to say that again what's the
primary method
is it is it marksmanship
is it battle exercises no they're saying
education now it's a primary but
a lot of people don't think that that
even falls in the top 10
for the marine corps education as marine
leaders progress through their careers
they need to develop mastery of the
concepts that provide an ability to lead
organizations like the marine corps
through cycles of
innovation cycles of innovation that are
essential
to staying at the forefront of
competition
these concepts go beyond just adaptation
they go beyond just that look if you're
just adapting to what's happening you're
wrong
i if i'm just adapting to what you're
doing dave i'm wrong
i'm wrong i need to be making you adapt
to what i'm doing right i'm going to be
on offense
they include topics like organizational
learning the ability for an organization
to sense changes
in its environment sense not react to
changes in this
but sense those changes you know what
lately i've been talking a lot about um
but just being more aware
of what's happening when people ask me
about the home life balance
you know how am i supposed to hey the
answer is you need to balance them
how can i help you i can help you by
making sure that you're more aware and
you're more
attuned to when things get off balance
you need
you need to sense those things more
and you need to sense changes in the
environment and approve improve its
effectiveness and efficiency in response
to those changes
change management when leaders are able
to implement needed change in an
organization while keeping its people
engaged
and the difference between sustaining
and disruptive innovation
which is essentially a difference
between incremental improvements of what
already exists
versus new and better approaches that
displace the old methods over time
that's what we're trying to do it is not
enough
for marines to educate themselves on war
and war fighting alone
such a narrow focus limits the benefit
they can give to the nation
most of a marine's career will be spent
training in the fleet marine force or
serving in a support
establishment understanding competition
and how the marine corps contributes to
it is an essential skill especially for
career marines
who will have the greatest impact on the
marine corps competitive attributes over
time
self-education in social economic
technological and other matters
beyond military history and leadership
are essential if marines are to excel in
competition
now what what's really cool about uh
working at echelon front and working
with all these different companies
is we get to work in economic
environments we get to work in
technological environments
we get to work in construction and
manufacturing we get to work in all
these different environments and what's
awesome
is when we can take what we know
and we can overlay it into those things
and get to see
and get to learn how our
principles impact even
in these this wide array of different
environments
and that actually makes us smarter
because when i see when i see how
a principal when i see how cover and
move
applies in a manufacturing plant and i
see how it
how it works in a financial company and
i see how it works
in a sales organization when i see all
those things
guess what i know better i know cover
and move better
i understand it better and that's what
they're talking about here
the better you understand all these
different aspects of what's going on
in the competition between america and
other nation states
the better you can see how your
how your organization contributes to
that competition and how you can better
contribute to that competition
the goal for education then is to foster
awareness
with the campaigning mindset of how all
capabilities available to marines can
fit into and support a larger
competition strategy it should improve
knowledge
of openness to the interests of
potential and existing allies and
partners
the outcome we seek from education is to
increase the ability of marines to
envision
greater possibilities in competition
next section talent management our
doctrine of maneuver warfare
places a premium on individual judgment
and action
wait a second are we talking about the
marine corps is everyone just following
orders no
we place a premium on individual
judgment and action
which also means we recognize all
marines of a given grade and
occupational specialty
are not interchangeable they should be
assigned to billets based on specific
ability and temperament
this expression of talent management
found in war fighting
applies equally as well to competing
people have different strengths and
weaknesses
the organizations that compete most
effectively place their people
in position to use their strengths
now we this is something we get asked
them quite a bit
and you know what you know i wrote about
leadership strategy and tactics hey if
i've got if dave's really good at at
at sales and he's not that great at
administrative duties
what should i do with him well i'll tell
you put him in sales
that's what he's good at let him go do
it now does that mean you let him just
ignore the administrative part and he
never has to touch paperwork and we hire
someone no no
we want to strengthen his weaknesses but
we want to utilize and capitalize
on his strengths they also coach their
people on the development of their
strengths and
link their use to the organization's
goals
some people excel at planning and
creating new designs for operations and
organizations others excel
at taking a blueprint and then
optimizing it so it works as well as
possible few have the ability to do all
these things with equal skill
to compete at peak effectiveness marine
leaders need to measure the talents of
the people they lead and then match
these skills to the duties they perform
organizations that do this well and for
a sustained period
also have a sustained competitive
advantage they maximize the performance
of their people over time
that answers a lot of questions if
you're in a leadership position
you find someone that's good at
something let them do it force planning
force planning which includes the
functions of design development and
management of the force for the marine
corps must balance
utility at many points on the
competition continuum with building a
force
that is a functional tool for the joint
force to use in winning battles
the output of this complex undertaking
must
serve the needs of competing generally
and
of war fighting in particular realizing
that they both
exist on the same continuum and that
they are interrelated shapes
shapes our overall approach to this
planning so
we could take the marine corps
and if we only wanted them to be good
at war fighting we would do things
differently
we would we would we would change entire
entire portions of the way we
raise marines we would get rid of
certain parts
hey what are you talking about we we
need to know marksmanship we need a
cover move we
we need we that's what we need to do we
need to be awesome at our tactics we
need to know how to win we know how to
interact with each other catch people in
the in the combined arms level that's
what we're gonna focus on
there's a whole nother bunch of stuff
that we focus on that well that the
marine corps focuses on
and what they're saying here is you have
to find that balance you got to be able
to compete
which means we got to be able to go out
and shake hands and make friends and
build relationships
and we got to be able to fight we've got
to find out
we've got it we've got to balance those
too and we've got to realize that
they're both interrelated
so this happens with companies where
companies
hey we've got to make money
we've got to make money that's great
guess what else we have to do we have to
maintain our reputation
because we can make a ton of money and
blow our reputation out the door
or we can have a great reputation and
now we're going bankrupt
so what do we need to do we need to find
balance on these two things
do this successfully the output of our
force planning should present a dilemma
to our potential competitors and defeat
their plans against us
the way we combined our organization the
way we combine our organization doctrine
training and equipment should produce a
competitive advantage or multiple
advantages
the options we choose within each of
these elements affects our
competitiveness over time for example if
we enhance the training for equipment
mechanics
so that they can operate for extended
periods without external support
then we also enhance our ability to
operate in austere environments for a
long period of time
the output of force planning is the sum
of choices
made inside each of these elements these
choices must be guided
by the goal of establishing competitive
advantages
which are useful for combat and
also useful for competition
having that goal when you're when you
when you make sure that you're sticking
with your goal
you you have to be guided your choices
are guided by the goal of establishing
these competitive advantages
that's what we're making our choices
based on is this going to give us a
competitive advantage or not
that's a very good way of simplifying
your decision-making process
what how is this going to give us
competitive advantage if it's not
why are we doing it i mean that that
competitive advantage is something you
have to have to be successful
and when you're making the connection to
business is
especially when you're sort of just
looking at the at the most basic level
of what consumers want
they've got a bunch of options they can
get the product or the thing you make
usually from a whole bunch of different
companies
and the competitive advantage is how you
can deliver that to what they want
better than everybody else and if what
you're doing isn't contributing to
that that i think over time
we've talked about complacency other
things the the inability to recognize
that you have to continue to contribute
to that competitive advantage that
that doesn't stay if you have that
competitive advantage now your
competitors are trying to erode that and
take that away from you
and so even the idea that it ha
everything you're doing
has to be designed to contribute to
either building or sustaining that
advantage
or or you're you're going to go away you
will be out maneuvered by your
competition
and i i love that even in the marine
corps they're saying
it's useful for combat and competition
those are two different things
and we're telling the marine corps the
marines are telling marines
those are two different things which is
interesting
because they're also saying throughout
this entire book that those are on the
same continuum
right so i'm going i'm going to do
something
that's going to be useful
at multiple locations on that continuum
right because if all we cared about is
you being good at combat
we would raise marines just like you
said in a totally different way yeah and
we would forgive a whole bunch of things
that happen like that's okay he can do
all those crazy things
because when we go to war we're going to
unleash that guy and
we know that's we know that's not enough
you you can't do that for a whole bunch
of different reasons
and the recognition that hey combat is
combat's gonna happen i mean certainly
in this day and age you're gonna see
some combat
but that might be fleeting you might get
one opportunity a one good deployment
but the competition piece and they've
sent it over that is happening
all the time in a whole bunch of
different ways
continuing on if we are to fully prepare
then marines need to also consider the
merits and challenges of
asymmetry in competition truly
asymmetric
asymmetric competition actions or
competitive actions
can impose costs on arrival for example
the original
assault breaker concept developed in
this 1970s and 1980s was an
asymmetric response to the soviet
advantage in armor and numbers so in
europe in the 70s and 80s they had this
massive the the
the soviet bloc had more armor than we
did and if they attacked it was their
armor versus
nato armor we they had the numbers so
they came up with this
this plan which was hey as soon as
something breaks out we're going to
attack
deep behind enemy lines with long-range
weapons
missiles to to to take out
all those extra tanks that they have so
that was that was something that we that
we came up with
to to negate their competitive advantage
yeah that will here it says improved
sensors with precision munitions to
negate this obvious advantages so
i guess i could have just read it
[Laughter]
the execution of force planning starts a
cycle
that begins putting forth a theory about
how we can contribute
to the nation's strategic competitions
throughout the continuum
building capabilities to bring theory to
reality and then testing the
capabilities through exercises and
operations
so again now they've gone from guessing
well i'm going from guessing
to hypothesis now it's putting forth a
theory right my theory is because that's
another word for guess it's another nice
word for i'm gonna take a guess
my theory is and then you take those and
you take those theories and you put them
to the test just like a hypothesis
in exercises and operations let's see
how they work other political actors
observe
this theory unfold and adapt themselves
so they can compete more effectively
against it that's what's going to happen
our observations of these adaptations
starts the cycle once again
force planning then is a continual
effort to stay ahead of potential
adversaries
thus we see that force planning itself
is a competitive act
and the marine corps must retain the
ability to reconfigure the force when
necessary to sustain its competitive
advantage or develop new ones
this ability starts with the mental
flexibility
that comes from humility and the
disciplined practice
of questioning assumptions
tattoo that on your forehead
well maybe on your forearm so you can
see it we don't want to have to look in
the mirror
this ability that we we should be
constantly
checking and and seeing where we're at
and seeing what adaptations the enemy is
making
the competitors are making and if we
don't have mental flexibility
we're wrong and if we don't have
humility we're wrong and if we don't
have discipline we're wrong
i think these people listen to the
podcast that's what i'm thinking
i'm thinking that the author's listening
to the podcast let us know
our awareness of the competition
continuum and its existence both above
and below the threshold of violence
broadens our view on forced planning so
the better you understand that
the better you understand that the the
game is much bigger than hey
we're gonna fight you with violence the
game is much bigger than that
our philo philosophy is that we can as
we have done in the past prepare marines
to succeed in competition
without sacrificing the marine corps
ability to prevail in battle
our understanding of ourselves must
include
how the marine corps fits into the
complex adaptive system
that is the naval service and the joint
force we know that the marine corps is
operated on both sides of the violence
threshold
and expect this to continue into the
future however
our campaigning mindset should lead us
to explore thoroughly
how the marine corps can contribute to
preventing war
again a little a little psyops how the
marine corps can contribute to
preventing war by regularly
operating below the violence threshold
even as marines are ready to
operate above it when required
i had some i had a note here and i don't
even know what it meant
when i talked about preparing the
marines to succeed in competition
without sacrificing the marine corps
ability to prevail in battle
i have in parentheses harder than you
think
oh and then i have uh as an example i
have college
sports teams okay so now now it makes
sense
the example i thought of is if you've
got a college sports team
if a simple example would be hey if the
only thing we want this
these athletes do is play football
everything's alpha
else is off the table well it gives you
a lot of capability on the football
field
but let's face it no one has anything
other than football when they're done
so you have to balance it it's an
example of you know if echo charles hey
he's not doing well in
geometry class he's got a d
we need to bench him well what if he's
our best player
we don't want to bench him but we have
to balance it
now on to the conclusion
the marine corps is one of the nation's
tools for the strategic competition that
is the normal state of event
of events in international relations and
by the way man
it as you watch the news
as you read the news which i recommend
if you think about the international
news
and you pay attention to the
competitions that are going
on it all this makes a lot more sense
when you see what china's doing when you
see what iran's doing
when you see what's going on in syria
which when you see what's going on in
the middle east when you see what's
going on
you see what's going on in europe when
you see when you start to think about
all those things from a more holistic
viewpoint and you
overlay the fact that it's one big
competition which look
we that's the way it is look at what
russia does
look at what russia does see
they are competing they are competing
and not only that
uh sometimes echo charles
people around russia like people other
than russia they're out playing flag
football
and russia's playing tackle
you know what i'm saying they're
you know someone else is playing um you
know
uh tai chi and they're playing combat
[ __ ]
and the tai chi people are thinking like
oh you know and also they get punched in
the face
or they're in a bad position more worse
they're in a bad position they don't
even know it
they don't know the capability that that
[ __ ] practitioner has
so you've got to pay attention that
you've got to start singing that these
little maneuvers
these little maneuvers that these other
nation states make they're not
i can't even believe i'm having to say
this right now but you can watch things
happen
and the way people respond to it it's
almost as if
it's just by chance that this other
nation state is making this maneuver
and and throughout this book and i wish
i would have
should have been doing this all along
you can you can you can find examples of
where this is happening
oh there's a boundary getting stretched
oh there's a salami slice
like all these things are going on oh
there's a there's a below the violence
threshold
maneuver and they're gonna back off
right before there's a response coming
this is what's happening all the time
a competition piece inside that too that
i think about is
we were talking earlier about hierarchy
everybody kind of knows the hierarchy
too
everybody kind of knows where we are in
the hierarchy and
what what that should tell us is that
they know
which is even more reason for them to to
be competing
all the time because they know where
they sit and they don't
like being there they don't like being
there and that is
true for nation states and that shop
that you're running
on that street corner if the hierarchy
is known which it almost always is
the other people in the hierarchy that
are underneath you don't
like that they also know that they can't
go toe-to-toe with you
they can't do the brute force method and
just run you out so they gotta out
maneuver you and now compete you with
little tiny moves here and there
and when you were talking about the idea
of i can't believe i have to say this is
the complacency that comes from being at
the top of
your food chain whatever it is
everybody else knows what's going on and
they're all trying to out maneuver you
so you shouldn't be surprised by any of
it that's what they're doing
you were saying earlier that you're out
on the weekends going to the club
their home sharpening their knives and
that's what they're supposed to be doing
and actually sometimes they're not even
sharpening their knives
what they're doing is they've got
a bar out in town that they're working
with
that's giving free drinks for you to you
and so even though they they can only
sharpen their knife so much so
what are they going to do they're going
to weaken you yeah
you got to be on the watch for that you
ever seen the movie training day
yes excellent film by the way
that's what that whole movie was about
essentially
so he was trying to you know he was he
basically had this new recruiter do
anything he wanted
to make the team or whatever right so he
sets him up to have to do
everything yet like he asked them to do
it started with making the smoke that
weed or whatever
if you watch the movie you'll understand
and even says in the in
one of the one of the pivotal parts when
he's manipulating him he says
hey it's chess it's not checkers so like
yeah you if you don't know you're in a
competition or whatever
essentially is the explanation where
you're just like oh yeah
today we're just sort of cruising where
and actually your
your example of like okay if you know
where you are in the hierarchy or
hierarchy
and you're let's say you're high and you
have all these challenger
people or entities right you're kind of
cruising
and they know they can't go toe-to-toe
with you with how you how you put it
but their move can be like
10 years down the road and they're
plotting for that you know
that that 10 years they're plotting for
that move or that series of moves you
know so we got denzel plays the
bad cop essentially yeah alonso who
plays the other one
jake is played by ethan hawk okay
so and that's the first escalation
is smoke and pot uh the first escalade
it starts in the beginning so like right
when the way he talks to him in the
beginning
where you could tell this guy jake is
like he just wants to make the team he
wants to do everything so it starts with
that
does that whole movie take place in one
day or is that just the name of the
movie oh that's all in one day
yeah yeah cause i was gonna say what's
what's interesting about that is
if ethan hawk jake
jake hoyt aka if he would have gotten a
brief prior to that day starting
that there was a competition happening
and there was maneuvers that were about
to be made
yeah he wouldn't have
he you know if he knows that this guy's
maneuvering it's like hey you need to
smoke the swede no
no yeah that's not happening because to
me once he got him to do that and i
don't know i don't remember the movie
that's that's almost checkmate right
that's almost checkmate like hey dude
we'll i'll get you
you need to get piss tested and now
you're out of the force and now you're
in trouble now you got a bad
uh reputation or not even a bad
reputation you got a what's it was an
re4 code in the military where you're
not allowed to get a federal job anymore
but
you got a bad thing happening you got a
dishonorable discharge
that's a checkmate move almost out of
the gate that's literally how it played
out
because that was like one of the first
major moves and it didn't come into play
until later when he was like hey
kill that guy but if he if he
would have been aware of the competition
that was happening
he would have known hey man this is not
a good move
hey i'm not doing that and that's that
totally actually would have
flipped almost flipped the checkmate the
whole deal the whole deal is flipped
but you're not aware of it you get
lowered in
well maybe i mean obviously it was a
movie
so there was he always had it
you've never put out that qualifier
before normally you just treat movies
like their reality
he he did in that i mean you're right
obviously but
um in the in that particular movie he
had him by the he had him by the balls
the whole time
because jake went into the thing he
wants to make the team like
he's even he's even he's even beyond not
knowing that he's competing
he's in like the he's in the beyond
opposite direction where he's thinking
that he wants to
like prove and be be a part of the team
the opposite of competing exact opposite
and it's funny you say that too where
it's like oh that was checkmate
where he was like when that came over
when he's like hey kill the guy he's
like no i'm not going to do it
he's like in fact you know what i'm
tired of this whole thing i'm turning
you guys in
he's like yeah go ahead but what what's
going to happen when they pull your
blood
you've been smoking weed and meth all
day or not matthew's like pcp or
whatever
all day having you and he's like looking
at him he can see the wheels he made him
smoke pcp or was it like intertwined in
the pot
yeah exactly right so it was weed so he
made him smoke the weed
and then after he smoked it he was like
dang i didn't know you smoked pcp
he's like you did i haven't but you have
now you know like that kind like
wait like did denzel's character smoke
weed as well no
he made him he put a gun to it yeah yeah
he was like hey
and the way he rashed have you seen
training the way ration
or rationalized it was like hey if you
refuse
weed in an undercover situation they're
just going to kill you so you got to be
ready to do this kind of stuff
and he's like oh no he's like he's like
i don't want you on my team
gun to his head i don't want you on my
team you know he puts a gun to his head
yeah
just as a like a like a demonstration oh
like what if it was like this
exactly right if we were on the street
you'd be dead right now like like that
kind of stuff
you know so it's kind of like he learned
it's almost like he jake felt like he
was learning this
big huge impactful lesson at that time
you know where he's like yeah you gotta
kind of
you gotta push it far sometimes you know
he wrote him out
yeah kind of or did he browbeat him he'd
be
brow beating him kind of both he
actually the whole movie is him doing
one or the other
it's weird it's a weird manipulation
thing yeah and finally when he was tired
of it he was like i'm not doing this he
was like oh yeah but you've been smoking
pcp all day
so you kind of gotta and all my guys who
are in on it
they're all gonna say the same thing and
he's like and he kind of has to do it
then soon like right after he's like hey
i know it's it's crazy i know but this
is how it is you know we got to be
wolves wait does he kill him spoiler
alert does he kill him
no uh since we're talking about training
day i have a small request you can you
may or may not
comply but let's face it when you give
me the
okay it sounds a lot like denzel
washington let's hear it that's
it i'm not gonna do it but that's
exactly where i got it from no i know
that because
even though i don't know that movie very
well yeah there was
when i when if i get a little overly
hostile with you
kind of one of your defensive mechanisms
is to throw that okay back at me dave
burke there was let's hear it
there was the time in training day in
the in the beginning he meets him at the
diner
right and he's like oh the guy jake he's
trying to make small talk you know it's
all awkward
and alonzo he's reading the newspaper
and he's like not talking to him it's
real awkward
so jake keeps trying to make small time
he's like hey shut up let me
read my paper jake's like oh awkward
so he can't help himself he has to say
something again just to fight the
awkwardness and then he's like puts down
the paper he's like hey tell me a story
he's like what are you talking about
he's like right you want i read the
newspaper for the stories or blah blah
blah he says this thing
it's like so you got to tell me a story
so i start telling my story and then
in the part when he's like oh yeah i'm
with this my training officer or she was
a girl or whatever he's like oh it's
a girl training officer oh man that's
and he's like yeah
he's like all right all right
so that's where it came from i did use
it in a different context but yes yeah i
got it from thank you
for that it always uh it always makes me
smile if i can push you to the point
where
you throw that at me yeah i know i did
my job for the day
yes sir the
manipulation you got to be on the
lookout for it
you got to be on the lookout because if
you're not competing all the time
if you don't recognize that you're
competing that's when you're going to
get caught
and you should never never
ever give that kind of leverage to
another human being
over you not to go back to training day
too much but
the smoking the smoking weed part
when he realized it when he was like hey
you've been smoking pcp all day haven't
you and he's like
he looked at him he's like you've been
planning this all day
he goes i've been planted it all week so
i'm saying though that's the
demonstration hey
you're always competing last week we
didn't even meet each other i was
already i was still competing yeah you
weren't
and look at you now that's insane
lessons are everywhere i kind of forgot
that i'm just retracing my steps for the
last four years and trying to make sure
i know what's actually going on here
back to the book for the conclusion as
professionals marines acknowledge this
condition and prepare themselves and the
marine corps to succeed in this struggle
adopting a campaigning mindset helps us
do this effectively as it aids us in
visualizing
the long timelines that often span years
and decades
this influences the type of education
they say
i mean it's so crazy
to not think about years and decades
that's if you're not thinking in years
and decades
you're gonna have some issues but yeah
none of us think in years i mean
whatever yeah
typically we don't think in years and
decades typically i mean we're for a
handful of things but that's it
and those handful things what i'm
talking about
this influences the type of education
they seek to prepare them for the
continual innovation that will be
required to sustain competitive
advantage and create new ones over the
course of a long-term campaign it also
influences their decision their thinking
on talent management because
the most competitive organizations are
the ones that get the most from their
people
by placing them in positions to use
their strengths on a regular basis
all of this preparation leads to the
type of agile force planning needed in
long-term competition resulting in a
succession a succession of force
planning that outcomes
planning outcomes that achieve and then
sustain competitive advantages
in the military element of national
power that's the
that's the conclusion there of chapter
three
well almost two hours deep so
good place to stop for now because i
don't want to crack open chapter four
yet
too much for one night
so we're always in competition
we should be in strategic competition
and all of this chapter three we are
preparing
for competition echo charles yes
here comes the tea up here comes the
softball coming your way let's see if
you can knock it out of the park
speaking of preparing for competitions
do you have any suggestions that will
help us stay prepared yeah take
supplements
and here's why straight to it yep here's
why
so you know okay so we'll start with the
joint stuff as we always do this is why
so a lot of times
i'm one of these people but well i don't
have joint problems
right until you do you see i'm saying so
that time if we're not thinking that
that if we're not considering the fact
that we might have these issues with
joints we're lifting weights we're doing
the jujits
and we're not anticipating the potential
for joint problems we're not going to be
competing in that way or aware of that
competition
okay we also need to be strategic in the
way that we're thinking
exactly because we are putting wear and
tear it might not hurt you
right now but guess what you're doing in
two years three years five years
you want to keep those things maintained
in the navy
in the marine corps that we know about
i'm sure it's this way in the army in
the air force as well
you're going to follow these maintenance
protocols
and they're going to help when you need
that element when you need that piece of
equipment when you need that shoulder
that elbow that knee
and look your knee let's face it it
could already
come with a kind of genetic disadvantage
you might have knees that are skinny
they need all the help they can get uh
yeah and if that's the case
hey you can get these supplements listen
we are doing something
at jocko fuel to try and
help out so what we're doing is if you
we know that shipping is expensive
we know that people are already paying
for the product and now all of a sudden
they got to pay for shipping too
and what we want to do is we want to
give you a way to
get that shipping cost down well we got
a way to get it down
we got a way to get it down a lot we got
a way to make it free
if you subscribe to any of these items
shipping is free
boom it was in january but now it's free
period straight up it's free period
and if you subscribe you save money too
you save like cost the cost goes down by
so if you want to
be prepared if you want to be
competitive
and you want to help out your bank
account
hey go subscribe and the shipping is
free
and you get 10 off which is pretty cool
so we're trying to make this stuff
more available easier to everybody so
that's what we're doing
joint warfare super krill discipline
discipline go
even the drinks shipping for free
mulch shipping for free strawberry
chocolate warrior kiss up everything
shipping for free
if you want to get it interesting yeah
that's good that's gonna help you later
it's gonna help a little bit all these
things are gonna help you later yep in
the campaign
true story also other things are gonna
help you
later you can also get this stuff at
wawa
where you can you can get the the ready
to drink what do you drink what'd you
have tonight
dave you went too deep and so did i yeah
we started recording late we both kind
of like
it was an early morning i know that what
flavors did we go on i went uh afterburn
orange with a dax savage it
uh follow up i went chaser savage chaser
i went i went i went taco palmer and
then i went
sour apple sniper jp appreciate it
that's what i went so i went we both
went back to back
back to back back to back i don't do
that very often no i was thinking too
like
i don't usually start hitting this this
late at night but i know that i
have work to do when i get home too so
that's a positive thing
you can get it you can also get the
stuff at the vitamin shop so
hit those up or get the free shipping
there you go it's true uh also at
origenmaine.com this where you can get
stuff as well
yeah there's a lot of other cool stuff
at origin or japanese.com
all american-made stuff by the way we
got boots
jeans jiu-jitsu stuff do you ever watch
pete
do you ever watch pete's do you ever
watch the origin usa
instagram story yes
so the other day pete roberts sure
he made a story about how he was all
fired up because
he bought we bought
we bought originusa.com okay
the the domain name the donate domain
name and he was all fired up and he was
he was he spent we spent 50 grand on
that
and he's all fired up it i don't know
did you know anything about buying
what's called a url do you know anything
about that yes yeah so
if it's a kind of a kind of a
a good word yeah they can be very very
expensive
i.e for origin usa
50 grand 50 000 and he's on there and
he's like you know a couple years ago
i wouldn't even dreamt of spending 50
grand for this but this is where we're
going we need
we need this new url so we're doing it
we're executing
and i i didn't i didn't didn't have time
because i saw the story
we me
also bought another domain name
which will be up soon and people
you could argue would say this is even
more a valuable
name url i bought
jocko.com jocko.com
and i almost posted this because what i
was going to say and this is the true
story
i bought jocko.com how much you think i
paid for it
origin usa costs 50 grand dave what do
you think how much do you think i paid
for it
i think it's unfair for me to answer
this question oh you already know the
answer me too oh yeah
okay so if you're wondering so i got
jaco.com
for one dollar no awesome guy owned it
and he's a trooper he's in the game and
he just reached out
to jamie and said hey i own jacqueline
and we get all kinds of things like we
get all kind of
jamie forced me to be like hey wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait and i see one title to an email
it says jocko.com and i open it up and
jamie's like
hey do you want me to do anything with
this i'm like he wants to sell me
jocko.com for a dollar and he also came
out here with his wife we had a cool
time we hung out
but yeah so i was going to post that
pete the businessman
pete the negotiator i was going to say
hey my business partner pete
great job negotiating the price to 50
meanwhile i got jocko.com for a dollar
you know what that is right there come
competition
i beat you pete yes sir that's uh below
market price
by the way yeah for sure that was super
cool so that should be up soon jocko.com
uh
and yes i won that competition pete cool
so origin went from
maine to straight up usa expanding it's
not there yet
yeah and right now but jocko fuel taco
oh i also bought jocko fuel i think i
bought that did you buy that
what'd you pay for it nine dollars 11.99
you got to love it you know market price
market price actually i don't know i
think you did buy that either way
yes it's true always i bought that a
long time ago yeah
yeah check but yes so yeah origin main
soon to be originusa.com
this is cool this is where you can get
americans made stuff
also we have a store jockostore.com i
bought that one by the way
back in the day this is where you can
get this one equal equal did you think
of that name yourself
that's a good original no i think you
started that one no actually i know i
didn't i really would be like oh what is
it you like jacques store and i was like
oh cool i guess we're going with the
theme
yes this is not a hard one to figure out
i remember too yeah you were like yeah
jocko podcast because it's
simple or whatever i was like oh it's an
online store
there you go chocolate store all day and
you know it's yours so
boom anyway this is where you can get
this one equals freedom uh shirts and
hoodies and hats and
a lot of cool stuff there there's a
t-shirt club called the
sh hurt locker
i did see now just so you know you no
longer have to say t-shirt club which
sounds super wacky you can just say we
also have the shirt locker
where you get a shirt everywhere you can
say it in a much cooler way yeah okay
you can just
exclude the lame things that sometimes
get said
yeah like all right well thank you for
coaching me up there
uh there's the sure shirt locker where
you can get a new cool t-shirt
every month high quality high speed low
drag as jocko always says
either way you've never actually even
heard me it's like it's a good thing to
check out it's a good thing to check out
so hey man if you think that's cool go
ahead and do that it's that taco
store.com like i said
you didn't mention the fact that at
origin main.com you can also get jeans
you can get boots i did did you yeah
dave did he say that
dude this we could be going two for two
here i have no recollection of you
saying that
okay well there's jeans and boots and
guess what they're american-made i said
that
it's true it's absolutely actually
didn't say that hey
no editing this is going to sound like a
dumb question from you
yes sir okay okay bear with me so the
origin boots are those good for snow
yeah not like i mean no tracking
snow yes if you're out and you're in
snow they're good if you're going to go
on a winter hike
in the woods right they're not going to
be optimal because they don't have any
insulation now if you put on a pair of
wool socks and maybe a little
polypropylene socks underneath them you
might be pretty good to go plus if
you've
added a little you know waterproofing to
it
you know we've got some oils you can put
in there you'd be good to go
got it but we if you're going on a trip
to the mountains where you're going to
it's gonna be cold when you're walking
around you'll be good to go normal stuff
yeah normal stuff
yeah i figured that what i guess another
dumb question right right
i thought it was kind of grounded
because when they're in maine yeah norm
um
it would be a dumb question if you were
from maine being that you're from hawaii
it's actually a totally legit
question your environment has not taught
you lessons that
a new englander would learn or someone
from michigan
or or montana would learn sure
wyoming people wouldn't be asking me
that question no
so it's not common knowledge for people
like us from the aina
all right cool boom there it is also uh
subscribe to this podcast if you want
and leave a review
on your podcast player of choice
yeah and we also have uh you can join
the the
jocko underground jocko underground.com
some people are asking questions
wait a second what's happening yes and
i'm like okay i explained it
this podcast jocko podcast the goal is
to never
change this the goal is to never put
this podcast
behind a paywall yes sir that's the goal
we want this to be free and as long as
that is humanly possible it will be
and the only thing you will have to
suffer through
is this section that we're listening to
right now
if you can bear with that which you
didn't even have to in fact i know that
there's only four of you listening right
now
if you can bear that you can listen to
this for free and you can also just
press stop and you didn't have to hear
any of this
crap thank you but but
look we we also we so we set this up as
a contingency
so we have an alternative platform that
we've built
we don't want to have other sponsors we
don't have somebody cutting in when
we're talking about
the battle of the bulge to tell you
about what kind of
underwear you should use we don't want
that to happen
so if you want to help us out with that
you can go and you subscribe to
underground and in order to
give you some benefit a tangible benefit
we're kind of we're recording another
podcast called
the jocko underground podcast and we
just kind of give some
other information they're a little bit
shorter they're just
some behind the scenes some some
amplifying information about what we
talk about some of where this podcast
came from how i thought of doing this
why we're doing this
so if you want you can do you're going
to jocko underground.com it's eight
dollars and 18 cents a month
which is a important number
okay and look we're not trying to uh
prevent people from being able to get
this information if you can't afford
that
and you still want to listen to the
jocko underground
podcast it's cool send an email to
assistance jockowunderground.com and
you we will hook you up and you will be
able to listen to the jocko underground
podcast so we have that going on
and and well we also have what else we
have we've got
the unraveling which actually daryl and
i are in
we are in we're in deep got a bunch of
stuff that we will have coming your way
for
coming your way for the unraveling
podcast we have the grounded podcast
which
we need to we need to do that
and the warrior kid podcast again i said
this the other day
i owe a book on january 31st
and when that's done my plan is to knock
out some warrior kid podcasts
we got a youtube channel where echo puts
up all the videos
of this podcast and other videos where
he makes a bunch of stuff blow up
using cgi because he thinks it's cool it
is cool
it's 100 cool thank you
well that's just your opinion uh we have
an album called psychological warfare
where i talk about overcoming moments of
weakness flipside canvas dakota myers
company
a bunch of cool stuff to hang on your
wall got a bunch of books leadership
strategy and tactics field manual
which i pull out to read quotes from
all the time when i'm talking to clients
oh yeah they ask a question oh yeah he
wrote about this here
dave all the time
[Laughter]
all the time so if you've got questions
about
what to actually do as a leader
get leadership strategy and tactics
field manual we also have the code the
evaluations the protocols we have
disciplinary freedom field manual
there's a new version out
we have way of the warrior kid four
field manual we also have whale the
warrior kid one two and three we have
about face
by david hackworth that i wrote the
forward for the new one mikey and the
dragons which a lot of people say is the
best
picture book ever a lot of people
saying that most people are saying that
we have a and then of course extreme
ownership and the dichotomy of
leadership
we have echelon front which is our
leadership consultancy go to
echelonfront.com
if you want help in your organization we
solve problems with leadership ef online
which is online courses
about leadership that you can bring your
whole company through
they can do them at their own pace you
can do it as a group there's all kinds
of ways to go through that program
that will get your whole company your
whole team
aligned and thinking the same way about
leadership
we have we have a live event that we do
a few times a year
2020 we didn't do any because there was
a
a virus out there 2021
we're reorganizing our dates we're
planning to do it go to extreme
ownership.com if you want to come to
that ef overwatch
we have leaders to place inside your
company that have
a military background that understand
these principles that we talk about
and if you want to help service members
active and retire their families gold
star
families and check out mark lee's mom
mama lee she's got a charity
organization
if you want to donate or you want to get
involved go to
america's mightywarriors.org
and if the last two hours you didn't get
enough
of my dictatorial diatribes
or you need more of echoes bewildered
bemoaning or dave's fanatical phrasing
you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter on instagram
which for those of you that only
understand what echo says he refers to
that as
the gram that and facebook dave is that
david r burke echoes
with charles and i am at jocko willink
and thanks
to all the people in uniform worldwide
doing what you have to do so we can do
what we want to do and the same goes to
our police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service
and all first responders we thank you as
well
for what you do every day and to
everyone else out there
competition is an enduring condition
it's always happening it's always
happening
and you need to be prepared and you need
to make sure
you are competing for the strategic win
for the long-term win
so pay attention to what you are paying
attention to
and then keep getting after it
and until next time this is dave and
echo and jocko
out